I will stand up here and give a glow to
value and never mention one time for any
of them to follow me and a lot more of
them will follow me then I'm gonna
follow that book move that you just did
the number one rule in business and
making money is you get paid when you
bring value the more value you bring the
more money you're going to make we
dedicate our entire life to making our
current time and civilization better to
adding something to the culture
rise and shine it's expresso time what's
up believe nation it's up in my one word
is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have an amazing gift inside
you that I want to see exploded onto the
world so let's start your day off right
together grab your coffee and sip on
today's message add a value over to you
Gary Vaynerchuk
[Music]
and wherever you are
so if you connect turn on and follow Jim
Bob on Instagram and like the Facebook
page for PR every my heart do you really
think that was a good idea I know bro I
honestly think that that was one of like
the worst moves I've ever seen because
and I'm not trying to razz you I I am
talking I'm trying to give you love I
love the passion to win the problem is
you tried to close on the first move you
brought them no value and you asked them
to bring you value like you gave like I
will stand up here and give a load of
value and never mention one time for any
of them to follow me and a lot more of
them will follow me then they're gonna
follow that bull move that you just did
[Applause]
I get it I get it but this was back to
the question that just happened this is
why I want you to win that move is
always gonna lose you can't go tonight
when you go out in Vegas and you see a
pretty girl at the bar you can't go up
to her and the opening move is like
here's my key let's go but but that's
what you just did let him hold it but
that's what you just did to this
audience with business I mean because
doing the right thing is the right thing
karma is practical you know I heard
somebody rant earlier right that's like
hey when I win I don't think it's coming
out of you the guy that closed I
couldn't know who was on stage but I
believe in that right because I love the
idea of 85 people here going and
listening to me winning I didn't make
anything for it but it then becomes
brand if she goes down and listens and
then two years later she's having dinner
with a friend and she's talking about
what happened to her life that friend
might be the CEO of GE you know I'm
playing with the biggest brands in the
world I'm not trying to monetize my
audience I'm trying to like just bring
the most value in the world and let that
lift all my other opportunities so I
think I think giving away your best
secrets is the greatest strategy for two
reasons karma is practical and leads to
more business but here's the secret and
it's even funnier 99% of these people
are not going to do anything about it
the we somewhere about five or six years
ago I realize this fact people aren't
gonna do anything with this like there's
still gonna be plenty for me and I'm
gonna be the most lovable guy ever I
love this the number-one rule of
business and making money is the more
value you bring the more money you're
gonna make
I covered this over and over and over
and over again on this channel but it
keeps coming back because it's so
important if you want to make money if
you want to win then you need to think
how can I provide more value that's it
stop looking for hacks stop looking for
shortcuts this is the shortcut provide
more value look at this YouTube channel
why do 1.2 million subscribers like you
watch his channel because I provide
value because this is helping people but
I don't have 10 million subscribers
because I'm not providing and not value
yet and so the answer for me to get the
10 million is I need to provide more
value I need to be better on camera I
need to select better clips I need to
bring more value I need this to be a
channel that everybody has to watch on a
daily basis when I do that I'll get
there and I can blame YouTube and
playing the algorithm and blame SEO and
blame all these other factors and say
well that's why I'm not a 10 million and
as long as I think that they'll stay
stuck here and I'll never get better and
I'll never hit ten million because it's
always somebody else's fault it's my
fault I need to do better I need to
bring more value and so whatever your
goal is right you have a goal you
haven't hit it yet that's why it's a
goal right it's something I spray Chanel
you trying to accomplish whatever your
goal is the immediate question that you
need to be asking yourself is how can I
bring more value to the people who are
crucial to allow me to reach my goal you
want to bring more people onto your
social media networks add more value my
youtubes 1.2 million my Instagram I'm
just starting it up I'm so pumped start
from the bottom Instagram
8,000 followers right now 8,000
followers is nothing it's amazing I'm so
excited I'm gonna win by providing tons
of value for 5 years then I'm gonna win
and so you want to win on social media
ask yourself how
bring more value you want to improve
your product you want to get more
customers ask yourself how do I bring
more value to my customers you want to
get media attention how do you bring
value to the media you want to get
instagramers or influencers to talk
about you how do you bring more value to
them you want to land more partnerships
and deals with OEMs ask yourself how can
I bring more value to them always
default to asking yourself how can I
bring more value and if you're not
getting the results that you're looking
for yet your default answer should also
be because you're not bringing enough
value yet and that sucks and that's a
tough pill to swallow but the key point
is yet like you can make this better you
can improve you just not provided enough
value yet and so if you focus on getting
better and I'm bringing more value and
improving your product your service your
contribution improving the value that
you bring them when you start asking
that question how can I bring more value
then you start getting interesting
answers you start getting answers that
help you move forward and closer to
achieving your goal but as soon as you
start blaming and complaining and
talking about the reasons why you're not
gonna win then guess what you won't win
either so remember the number one rule
in business and making money is you get
paid when you bring value the more value
you bring the more money you're going to
make now Gus's special bonus clips for
you but before that question of the day
what is the thing that you bring insane
value to what are you one of the best in
the world at what are you Michael Jordan
level talent add I would love to hear
from you leave it down the comments
below thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso and enjoy the
bonus clips
Spray so give me
you don't realize I am so frustrated
like I am so frustrated like I am so
I've got so much I want to give I've got
ideas on color palettes I've got ideas
on silhouettes and I've got a million
people telling me why I can't do it you
know that I'm not a real designer I'm
not this I'm not a real rapper either
I'm not a real musician either like I
don't know how to play the piano like
I'm an artist I went to art college I
went to art college and was looked at
like I'm soft cuz I like wore like
Italian clothes you know I'm saying when
I'm rapping in front of camera and my
pants is tight trying to spit a verse
for care you know that's the same when
I'm sitting there you know like sitting
there out of fashion show like I'm there
because I appreciate Phoebe Philo I
appreciate Rav Simmons I appreciate
Riccardo Tisci and I look at them as my
peers as creative people who dedicate
their entire life to making something
better for the world is that mean let me
explain what anybody that knows are
artists and you know someone that's
giving that if you know artists there's
only one thing you can say give or ask
them when you see them there are two
words thank you there's no why did you
do this you're what they what's that
no we dedicate our entire life to making
our current time and civilization better
to adding something to the culture and
there is only two words that you can say
thank you add some value there's a true
societal and business value proposition
there's a contribution I find and I
don't do this for reasons other than the
fact that you can't long term build a
viable business without making a real
contribution most people look at they
can start a business do an IPO make some
money almost always that leads to
businesses that are round trips what I
call good they go up and go down
to build a durable business you really
have to focus on the value proposition
life should be incredibly valuable to
you if you really value your days like
that day becomes valuable so because
your day is valuable you get stuff done
you know why a lot of people end up
feeling really broke is because they're
not valuing their day they're broke
because they added no value to their day
they were reading celebrity gossip
magazines they were screwing around
online they were doing nothing that
actually moved the needle in terms of
their personal progress and their
professional progress so value this day
you want to make more money get serious
about tomorrow value that day ask how
you can add more value into the day
really work the day and as you do that
over and over and over again you ask how
can I serve how can I contribute how can
I take it to the next level
you do that long enough the breakthrough
happens the magic happens
and the money takes care of itself raise
your standard Apple at the core its core
value is that people with passion not
one drop of most self-worth depends on
your it's something cement
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten most of success I have
a very special secret video for you
these are the individual clips that I
have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link in description for
details